[Musique]
les défis de demain les défis de demain
sont multiples chacune et chacun des
intervenants aura sa propre approche les
éléments pour ma part je considère qu'il
s'agit de l'usiné société phem et
l'épanouît au ma part il nous faut un
taux de chômage nul en particulier parmi
les jeunes pour ma part cela peut se
faire bien ce que j'appelle et les
l'entrepreneuriat et le développement de
l'économie numérique
il s'agit d'avoir un développement
économique inclusif qui se fonde sur des
innovations technologiques en
particulier mais pas uniquement
il s'agit également d'avoir une masse
critique des frères africains dans
certaines technologies et discipline on
a parlé tout à l'heure d'intelligence
artificielle d'internet des objets
beaucoup d'autres domaines font partie
de ces détecteurs de djezzy nous devrons
monter en compétences dans cette
technologie et être de véritables
acteurs
jeunesse numérique entrepreneuriale
voici trois mots on a l'habitude
d'entendre très souvent alors est ce un
effet de mode passager parle-t-on ici de
thèmes fondamentaux de nos sociétés nous
voulons croire qu'il s'agit de thèmes
fondamentaux de nos sociétés les
sociétés africaines en particulier la
jeunesse une population six jeunes en
afrique est si prometteuse le numérique
le numérique qui bouleverse nos vies qui
bouleverse nos métiers nos manières de
travailler et même nos façons de nous
regarder les uns les autres nous façon
de communiquer nos manières d'interagir
l'entrepreneuriat est simplement une
volonté de s'affranchir d'un responsable
hiérarchique un peu pauvre ont un peu
trop exigeant de gloire d'être son
propre patron de ne pas avoir de
contraintes au quotidien il faudrait
peut-être plus que ça pour devenir
entrepreneur ne serait ce pas une
vocation
l'entrepreneuriat ne se choisit pas par
dépit
on ne devrait pas devenir entrepreneur à
ce qu'on n'a pas obtenu d'emplois
salariés et je sais combien dans notre
culture
il est beaucoup plus valorisé d'avoir un
poste dans une multinationale que de
devenir son propre patron
en côte d'ivoire on a une expression
qu'on une gamme
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché
cela pourrait être ce qu'un parent
dirais à son enfant qui quitteraient un
poste d'ingénieur télécom
deux responsables de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information dans une
multinationale de la place pour créer
son entreprise
ma fille mon fils qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et pourtant
l'entrepreneuriat est à valoriser mais
on ne devient pas entrepreneur du jour
au lendemain sur un coup de tête
c'est un chemin difficile
certains me vous le savent je vois mes
acquiesce c'est un chemin difficile mais
ô combien passionnant et gratifiant
quand on a dans certains objectifs il
faut de la patience et énormément de
persévérance pour être entre mode
entrepreneurs certains d'entre vous le
savent je le vois bien
bingo on bosse et deutsche jugend show
which in fine aw des new york
vous êtes notre propre patron et vous
pouvez décider de travailler de minuit à
18 heures de 5h à 23h
si vous le souhaitez mais vous ne
travaillerez certainement pas mois de
18h sur les 24 heures de la journée du
chou il vaut mieux le savon avant de
créer sa start up on en parle beaucoup
mais finalement qu'est ce qu'une
serveuse steijns
on commence une entreprise jeune on
monte on se développe on grandit
peut-être un fort potentiel de
croissance mais également un
entrepreneur jeunes ou non doit avoir
une liste de priorités bien clair sinon
il serait facile de se disperser
les entrepreneurs rencontrent de
nombreuses problématiques on ne pourrait
pas toutes les citer mais parlons de
quelques unes
une jeune entreprise qui a un fort
potentiel de croissance qui est fondée
généralement sur une innovation et qui a
besoin de lever des fonds pour se
développer
jeune on a souvent besoin de
renforcement des capacités
aujourd'hui le numérique nous permet de
nous former par nous mêmes à travers des
plateformes en ligne
on parle de boucles c'est un terme à la
mettre encore un autre massi open online
pouces
on peut obtenir des diplômes en ligne
sans quitter son lit sion le swing n'y a
plus de limites aux abois et on en a
parlé tout à l'heure les jeunes
entrepreneurs ont un problème d'accès au
marché qui ferait confiance à un jeune
de 15 20 30 ans qui le surcroît vient
nous apporter quelque chose
on n'a jamais vu quelque chose qu'on
connaît mal quelque chose qui vient
bouleverser notre façon de faire qui lui
ferait confiance
il est important de commencer petit
l'entrepreneur peut commencer dans son
simple et commencez à éprouver la
qualité de ses services et de ses
produits à travers son cercle restreint
bénéfices et de feedback pour améliorer
son offre de service puis grandir
grandir et grande vers l'été son marché
s'accroître
l'accès au financement le nerf de la
guerre
combien de jeunes entrepreneurs n'avons
pas entendu dire j'avais un excellent
projet mais je suis mort avant d'avoir
et cloud faute de financement mais là
encore il y a des idées reçues
l'entrepreneur a accès à ce qu'on
appelle communément le love money vous
connaissez cette expression certaines
personnes croient en nous et sont en
mesure de nous accompagner
financièrement mais évidemment à des
montants assez modestes au départ puis
on peut grandir et accéder à des
structures de microfinance à des
business angels
à défaut on venture capital etc mais
tout ça se fait par étapes
bien évidemment ne pas avoir les yeux
plus gros que le ventre peut-être et
fonctionner par paliers pourraient être
une solution au point de blocage que
rencontrent beaucoup de nos jeunes
entrepreneurs
et puis cette fiscalité et fiscalité qui
semble lourde si lourde parfois sur les
épaules de nos jeunes entrepreneurs
l'un patente la tva le bis et on
pourrait en faire une chanson
évidemment des mesures existent déjà et
il s'agit d'aller se renseigner d'aller
chercher dans les textes existants ce
dont on peut déjà bénéficié mais cela
reste une problématique qui doit être
adressée
au milieu de tous ces défis existent des
success stories une jeune ivoirienne a
créé un bracelet connectés contenant les
informations de santé des uns et des
autres ce qui permet une prise en charge
plus rapide une jeune ivoirienne a créé
un e-magazine qui fait la promotion de
héros nationaux africains sont de
l'attaqué ita chaka zoulou le sultan des
bamoun au cameroun etc etc
un jeune ivoirien a créé un service de
dossiers patient informatisés qui permet
d'éviter les grosses piles de papier
poussiéreuse dans lesquels on essaie de
retrouver votre historique médical et
qui permet avec un identifiant unique
d'être prise en charge de manière
appropriée
il a osé aller plus loin quitter la
capitale et s'installer dans une petite
ville à l'intérieur du pays voici un
autre défi de demain développer
l'intérieur de nos pays et pas
uniquement les capitales il a osé et
s'en porte très bien aujourd'hui un
jeune ivoirien est claire et connect des
villages internet partout dans la côte
d'ivoire un autre axe est une
application de gestion des consommateurs
et créer une filière à l'international
un autre encore utilisent des déchets
organiques pour en faire du biocarburant
et de la biomasse un jeune ivoirien
utilise l'intelligence artificielle pour
détecter en amont une maladie qui
s'attaque aux plants de cacao le swollen
shoot
la jeunesse numérique révolutionne déjà
nos sociétés aujourd'hui je suis linda
nanan valley je me définit avant tout
comme une enfant de dieu comme une fille
une soeur et une mère en plus d'être une
épouse de mon petit garçon que je vous
présente
j'ai grandi en côte d'ivoire j'ai eu
l'opportunité d'étudier et de travailler
dans plusieurs pays répartis sur trois
continents
je suis aujourd'hui enseignant chercheur
au sein de l'école supérieure africaine
des technologies de l'information et de
la communication et j'ai le plus plaisir
et l'honneur de diriger la fondation
jeunesse numérique de côte d'ivoire des
jeunes sensibilisés à l'entrepreneuriat
numérique
une caravane nationale les appels à
projets des centaines de candidatures et
de projets incubés des emplois créés des
partenariats clés avec des incubateurs
de différents pays
voici ce qui pour nous représente une
contribution à la résolution d'un des
défis de demain qui s'adresse dès
aujourd'hui réduire à zéro le taux de
chômage des jeunes en transformant des
demandeurs d'emploi en créateur
d'emplois comment ça tu eu peur il nous
revient à tous de franchir le bas comme
un star de peur comme un jeune
entrepreneur
il nous revient à tous de le demander
pourquoi nous sommes sur cette terre
finalement pourquoi ça moulin il est
impossible que je sois né seulement pour
payer des factures et pour mourir pour
prendre le bus le métro la voiture
travaillé toute la journée rentrer à la
maison
faire la vaisselle travaillait encore me
coucher et repartir le lendemain matin
pour un autre tour il a certainement
quelque chose plus grand que cela de
plus grand que moi
de plus grand connu à chacun alors de
les terminer sa mission et au travers de
ce parcours plusieurs leçons ont été
apprises mais le son son mari
mais le son se résume ici nos valeurs de
base des valeurs saines et des valeurs
bien ancrée sont une clé déterminer sa
mission personnelle et peut-être plus
facile pour des croyants ou peut-être
pas mais toujours est il que tous les
objectifs personnels ou professionnels
devraient découler de cette mission
personnelle est arrivé en fin de vie
sans avant de terminer sa mission
personnelle serait un peu triste un
jeune entrepreneur franchi le pas ils
osent franchir le pas il ne sait pas de
quoi sera fait demain ils osent y aller
parce qu'il a une vision alors qu'elle
sait qu'il a une mission
prenons donc exemple
être conscient les différents
principauté la ligne malmène la vie
normale mail mais chaque scène chaque
difficulté chaque épreuve contribue peut
être à l'accomplissement du destin de
notre univers les défis de demain ça
draine aujourd'hui je vous laisse sur
cette petite note d'humour calque ex ami
philippe émergence
[Musique]